for most people going to the movies is a
surefire form of stress relief one
that's specifically intended to distract
us from the turmoil of our own lives for
at least an hour or two of course that
can occasionally backfire because some
films just won't allow you to switch off
your brain and check out of the world
for even one single minute that's not
always a bad thing though in fact some
of the best films out there are good
simply because they challenge our hearts
and minds here are some of the most
stressful movies you'll still want to
watch 7 when 7 made its way to theatres
is back in the fall of 1995 the world
was simply not ready but Dave adventures
relentlessly bleak Symphony of Sorrows
is still a masterpiece that continues to
serve as a bizarre gory mirror for moral
and societal excesses the film opens on
a dour note and only gets more desolate
desperate and stressful with every
moment that follows still 7 is so
meticulously constructed obsessively
executed and skillfully acted by its
leads that even at its most gruesome
it's almost impossible not to want to
watch it all unfold whether it's because
of sevens obsessive nature it remains
one of the most rewatchable movies ever
made
no matter how difficult it is mother
speaking of directors who like to push
buttons Darren Aronofsky is another
director known to break boundaries but
nothing in his riveting collection could
have prepared audiences for the brain
bomb that was his 2017 offering mother
set in a tranquil secluded country home
the film follows a struggling poet and
his young wife as they try to write and
remodel their home that peaceful
existence is disturbed with the arrival
of unexpected guests things quickly get
out of hand as mother propels itself -
it's shocking but inevitable finale the
moments that lead us there come with a
constant feverish upping of the ante
watching mother is an emotionally
draining affair which might explain the
movies box office problems but like the
best of Aronofsky's films the anxiety
and discomfort caused by watching it is
still totally worth it
buried for much of his early career
thought of taking Ryan Reynolds
seriously as an actor just seemed
laughable but many film goers opinions
of Reynolds as an actor were forever
changed after seeing his nerve-wracking
2010 micro budget thriller buried the
whole film takes place in a coffin
buried somewhere in the Iraqi desert and
Reynolds is the sole actor and yes he's
buried inside the coffin if you're
claustrophobic sitting through this
movie is a lot like subjecting yourself
to a ninety five minute anxiety attack
and even if you're not afraid of
enclosed spaces buried is still tough to
tangle with but if you can make it
through the cramped space of the film
it's a first-rate thriller with a few
clever twists some surprisingly
insightful commentary and an impressive
dramatic performance from Ryan Reynolds
who doesn't snidely snicker or break the
third wall even once under the skin
sometimes it's hard to pinpoint exactly
what it is about a movie that stresses
you out but in the case of Jonathan
Glaser's under the skin it's quite
literally everything
the film's photography music acting
sound design and editing are designed
with the single goal of keeping viewers
on edge the result is a challenging
deeply disturbing movie that you don't
really watch as much as you experience
at the same time though it's also a
profoundly engaging ambitious picture
that hypnotizes viewers into entering
its darkness as it examines complex
topics of identity extraterrestrial
morality and what it means to be human
at the center of that exploration is the
single weirdest and possibly strongest
performance of Scarlett Johansson's
career the film works best if you know
as little as possible going in but
Watchers should be warned that if you
feel uneasy while watching the flick
that just means it's working enemy
deneva loves doppelganger thriller enemy
is adapted from a novel by experimental
novelist josé saramago and follows an
average man whose middling life is
thrown into flux when he spots his exact
double in a movie what follows is a
study of identity and modern isolation
that finds Jake Gyllenhaal in top form
playing dual roles and Vilna of
beginning to tease the daring style
that's become his trademark in the years
it's also worth noting that spiders
figure prominently in the film which
means there's a fair amount of arachnid
angst involved in watching me more
importantly though the film is also rife
with metaphorical webs that the director
uses to pull viewers further into the
sticky deadly center enemy is one of
those rare movies that's distressing
enough to just watch and even more so
after the credits have rolled and you're
stuck trying to figure out what the hell
just happened
bug William Friedkin directed one of the
most unnerving films ever made with
2006's buck but odds are you've never
heard of it bug features one of the
finest performances of Ashley Judds
career and a breakout turn from the
great Michael Shannon perhaps one of the
reasons bug hasn't quite broken any
box-office records is that it's hardly a
feel-good affair the bulk of the film is
set inside a dingy hotel room and
follows a damaged woman who seems to be
on the verge of a fresh start after
meeting a kind' war vet when her new pal
turns out to be one deeply unhinged
individual what follows is a terrifying
descent into madness Friedkin keeps the
action taught throughout making the
proceedings extra stressful by using
expressionistic lighting shooting his
stars and unflattering close-ups
featuring a handful of body horror
scenes that will definitely make your
skin crawl bug is essentially the
cinematic equivalent of poking at a raw
nerve for a couple of hours but it's
well worth the pain
[Music]